gigi hadid and Zayn Malik are having a
girl I'm feeling so overwhelmed with
happiness and excitement on Tuesday et
confirmed that the two were expecting
their first child together
and on Wednesday TMZ reported that
they're expecting a baby girl now a
source tells ET quote the couple
recently found out the sex of the baby
and are over the moon adding that they
are excited to be welcoming of girls to
their family the on-again off-again
couple first started dating in 2015
before announcing their split in March
2018
then in January they sparked
reconciliation rumours when they were
spotted together in New York City Gigi
Alba confirmed they were back on when
she shared this pic of the former One
Direction bandmate on Instagram on
Valentine's Day alongside the caption
hey Valentine Z on the farm
he's obviously so gorgeous but really
the way that we could have conversations
and kind of just were really interested
in the same things and it was really
easy the source tells ET that the
lovebirds are now very excited about
starting a family quote it was like they
never skipped a beat and knew what they
had was special the couple and their
families are overjoyed being is very
special to me and
yeah Gigi's momma Yolanda Hadid told UT
back in 2017 that Zane has her stamp of
approval he's just a really good person
you know he comes from very humble
beginnings oh he's just a normal guy and
he's he's a good human being
[Music]